[Musik]
um viertel vor sieben stellt hans peter
amstutz sein velo hinter dem schulhaus
in illnau effretikon abgeschlossen habe
er es noch nie gesagt der
oberstufenlehrer und noch nie sei etwas
passiert
so hält er es seit über 40 jahren
um seine sekundarklasse zu ende zu
führen hängt der 66-jährige noch ein
schuljahr an die einen sind froh darüber
sie halten ihn für kompetent und
engagiert die anderen sehen in ihm einen
pauker und ein auslaufmodell
im sommer ist alles vorbei amstutz geht
in den ruhestand
vorige mitgenommen
das
den ganzen freitag morgen unterrichtet
amstutz seine klasse die dritte siegten
früher ist das realschule werden
persönlich begrüßt
für den lehrer ist das ein wichtiges
ritual zur kontaktaufnahme und als
startsignal in den schultag
das erste was wir anpacken ist gleich
bei diesen sprichwörtern hängen wir noch
einmal eine die seite 13
der unterricht beginnt mit sprachübungen
das sei bitter nötig sagt amstutz
denn für die mehrheit der klasse ist
deutsch einer fremdsprache
was heißt sich aus dem staub machen
das heißt dass sich aus dem staub machen
ja lukas auf die finger sehen sich
nehmen und ihm in den weg stellen
sein geld aus dem fenster wer braucht
noch den schluss gleich viel in den tag
hinein leben jemanden auf die tasche
liegen in der tinte sitze
der chef sagt ich habe ihnen gekündigt
und der chef sagt das ist die bürostuhl
und sorglos will sie nicht mehr los ist
nicht los die gott aus ich wünsche ich
niemandem das ist klar da nicht und
grammatikalischen dreimal gefrieren ist
das info
das nicht gilt das ist brauch könig und
eigentlich dass gärten sind dass sich
konzentrieren
man ist ganz locker auf das ganze also
das geld wurde zum ritter uns laufen als
sich elementar wichtig dass man mit der
mittleren straße muss ich sagen das war
so blöd vom lehrer
er kann aber auch anders zb wenn ein
schüler gegen regeln verstößt
im schulzimmer gilt ein striktes
handyverbot ein kaugummi verbot und ein
mützen trag verbot also ich finde es
besser das rad stand benz e klasse die
schwache rostocker
ich bin am morgen strenger lehrer nach
einer kurzen partnerarbeit folgt wieder
frontalunterricht für amstutz noch immer
die effizienteste unterrichtsform nun
wie muss man sich das vorstellen
geschichtsstunde zweite weltkrieg
invasion der normandie amstutz
lieblingsfrau bin da ganz gut was ist
das für ein land e
damit wieder klar sehen was ist das so
england und ihr seht ihr das was ich
gesagt habe was waren darunter tücher
versteckt wir also diese panzer die
ausdauer
sie schirmen zu wahren da wo habt
romantiker versteckt irgendwo habe ich
die titel gezeichnet jacqueline ja
überall da in frankreich waren solche
hecken da waren drei millionen mann da
war eine million man aber die hälfte
davon war halb ihn verliert die gingen
jetzt ja die großen schiffe in den
hängen in den häfen in england 4000
schiffe nun muss ich ein paar sachen
sagen was robl gemacht hat um den
angriff abzuwehren
ganz verrückt es verschiedene hauptstadt
unternehmen
vielleicht beginnt also spannend sind
die disco needs und ein coaching - so
sah das ganze dann herrscht ruhe
gestalten in den heften und an der tafel
ist für amstutz ein didaktisches mittel
zur förderung der konzentration ganz
traditionell im normalfall haben
in dem moment wo nicht am nachmittag
stehen am nachmittag durch vorbereitet
und wenn ich dann zeichnet gab für mich
ist so ein film ab das heißt ich tue das
zeichnen also nicht nur die flugzeiten
hinaus überlegt wird um zeichnet ihr als
ich begriff dass da die mit der band
zuvor rücken dass auch verstehe oder
damit der steilen waren das muss unser
co
kurz vor 12 holt sich hans-peter amstutz
in der nahe gelegenen bäckerei nüssli
dance mittag bis in den 40 jahren
unterricht sind am lehrer generationen
von schülern vorbei gezogen darunter
auch die bäckereiverkäuferin und heute
wiederum deren tochter der
unterrichtsstil von amstutz habe sich
über die jahre verändert beobachtet die
verkäuferin ganze fragt sie führen wie
ein rückzug praxis ganzen super gute
lehre und forschung der einzige und geht
es wirklich mehr bäcker hans uli nüssli
ist an bildungsfragen besonders
interessiert in der raumschaft kommt
denn hier zocken zur diskussion über
schulreformen diesen status personen ich
kann natürlich mit dem über das
diskutiert und auch meistens sind immer
einige übernommen und daraus sind immer
einige scheer ist sehr kritisch
gegenüber schulform das begriff ich habe
die zahl bei kind und mann sehr viel
drive aurora capital sind und ich finde
einfach zu viel und ich finde auch nicht
sich entscheidend für der scholz arena
sondern der zu viel neues ist amstutz
ein coil als bildungsrat und zeitweise
höchster lehrer des kantons eckte er
damit an die volksschule ist nicht groß
aber doch revolution minister hans-peter
amstutz als real ale kantonsrat cvp und
es parallel solcher lehrerinnen und
lehrer vertreter weil sie finden dass
digitale von freunden schwer mich ganz
heftig war mit 21 jahren der inneren
ich stand also das ist der strahl die
die schule muss wieder suchen wo haben
element wo haben wir strukturen schaffen
für viele ist das ich trage ich habe
vielleicht nichts übrig die zweite mit
wo sie sich wohlfühlen
[Applaus]
früher sei kein reformer handschuhen
anschlag gebracht und er sagte schon mal
die hand die unternehmerische freiheit
der verloren karriere profisafe ist
schönste und ich verkrampfe mir das
immer noch dass ich das pädagogische
unternehmertum cup holte aber wir haben
die zahl der us politik habe der
mögliche blödsinn gemacht dass das der
real lehrer zum beispiel gordon gibt da
wird halbiert
man macht den orten viel einfiel zwei
treffen über studieren dpa das ist das
ja eine andere person heimischen
hochschule gotische hoch schon das ist
tot sind und das macht der lehrerberuf
gratis schwächere kaputte beziehungen
aufbauen
ich muss können die großen
unterrichtsblöcke weil ich mich mit der
jugendlichen kontakte und ich muss sagen
dass ich so etwas schönes wenn sie das
gegen individualisierten unterricht
gegen eine akademisierung der ausbildung
gegen eine zweite fremdsprache in der
primarschul das überfordere die
schwächeren schüler ist amstutz
überzeugt diese liegen ihm am herzen und
sie wieder fördern
sogar am frühen mittwochnachmittag seit
jahren ist das sein heiliger fußball
termin
der 66 jährige ist trotz knieverletzung
hart im nehmen
im team spielen freunde kollegen aber
auch schüler
vor allem sie wieder fördern
die fröhliche er
yahoo
[Applaus]
so im team wie erleben sie das
einnahmeziel schülerteam geschützt das
letzte mal und gleichzeitig als und
förderer gibt tipps
er bewahrt und man ist wieder steuerlich
die stangen heraus mit zwischen uns
nichts vor parallel hat völlig recht
hier mitgebracht und ist quasi auch
viele bürger für die seit drei jahren
spielen die schüler mit und es zeigt er
willkommen
dieses bereichen jedoch noch mit der
kutsche mit mehr am stück
also es macht spaß und er wird fit
werden
dadurch dass witt braucht also mehr als
die spd
aus welchen konditionen witz verbessert
sport hilft stärker zu werden davon ist
der oberstufenlehrer überzeugt gerade
bei der heutigen generation abends hat
amstutz noch ein heimspiel
als gastreferent bei seiner
evangelischen volkspartei bei der 35
jahre mitglied ist das christlich
wertkonservative gedankengut sei seine
heimat sagt er
hier fühle er sich verstanden an diesem
abend zeichnet der lehrer ein düsteres
bild der heutigen handy generation und
der überforderten schule muss mich sehr
schwer einen rhythmus grüne wissen sie
ich habe die ganz nacht oder computer
sprichwort wäre der ganze wäre stellt
sie sich vor zerstören dann in und
völlig erschöpft und die schüler hat ein
relativ viel zeit braucht bis bis wieder
die achse sind für normale lehre die
handy generation die ihr verbringt hat
das deutsche studio ganze sieben stunden
pro tag sieben stunden pro tag mit
digitalen medien
das ist ganz unglaublich dass ich so
viel wie die oberstufenschüler rendsburg
und hoffe dass ich der helle wahnsinn
den jüngern geht so viel pessimismus
denn doch zu weit
die zehnjährige vom raum stützen ich
glaube dass man die digitale medien hat
wirklich vermehrten schon aufbringen
wenn es immer sehr alt im alltag nach
dem frost möglich
hier entgegen der stadt verbot in der
führenden medienkompetenz
zum beispiel dass man inhalte wie
bringen wir immer damit umgeht dass man
unter umständen halter relative zählt
will machen heutzutage haben wir alles
im schrank rostige tolle meter sind dann
für besser kontrollieren was
entsprechendes klima könnte dann
kontrollieren jetzt rund dementiert
das ist dass das ist möglich dass man
die sagen sich die alte tugenden
das ist so dass man für stadt und der
verlässlichkeit zuverlässigkeit gut
bezahlte schweizerische tugenden als
negativ oder positiv sehe ich sehr
positiv und die neue tugenden
das wäre so es vernetzt sie ist kreativ
ist flexibel
wir zählen wir die balance wieder
herstelle kann am ehesten stimmt zum
teil nehmen
ich mag die jetzige generation hat als
und ist defizitär struktur dass ich
unglaublich amstutz hat eine mission und
sein konservatives wird system als
orientierung in einer immer komplexeren
welt findet anklang
so tritt sie als konservativ sind auch
sind war das ist mehr als ein pseudo
liberalismus als macher aber es wirkt
verteilten zurück im klassenzimmer
lehrer amstutz verkündet die noten im
plenum
das sieht er nicht als pranger sondern
als motivation sagte auch in der physik
stunde fordert der lehrer geballte
aufmerksamkeit
er bietet aber auch einiges wie viel ist
das gerade wenig aufregendes kommen sich
merken wie viel ist das 100 gramm
schokolade ist die anziehungskraft von
einem jugend newton was wir passieren
wenn ich jetzt da so richtig nach vorne
gehen einen schritt machen was wird auf
passieren mannschaft stimmt ich habe sie
nicht abgestoßen und ich machte nur den
schritt das heißt kraft gleich gegen
kraft heute wie die physiker sagen
aktion gleich reaktion
rückstoß prinzip sprachübungen und
zweiter weltkrieg das jonglieren mit
verschiedenen fächern ist die
leidenschaft von hans-peter amstutz
träge
er sieht sich als allrounder ganz wie
früher sein ziel ist es den schülern die
welt ins klassenzimmer zu holen
gerade die generation die als die reale
technik bemühen so krank ich finde das
ganz toll dass es noch richtig
funktioniert mit rufen und sie sehen
deutliches ja witzig weit gekommen dass
wir sie nicht einfach denn ich glaube
das bunte trio das im alltag frauen
physik immer wieder erlebt haben was
mehr als bahnen aus der ganze saal die
schulen also da die kollektoren die
brüche zu die bruch im raum blasen
physik im alltag erleben frauen und
mannen also da ich keinen unterschied
sie sehen sich prügeln würde selbst
wichtige druck diese physikstunde wird
die klasse wohl nicht so schnell
vergessen
[Musik]
ein klassenlager am bielersee
auch das gehört zum festen repertoire
jahr für jahr während viele
berufskollegen diese verantwortung
scheuen sagt amstutz er sei den
jugendlichen dieses gruppenerlebnis
schuldig mit dabei ist auch seine
tochter christine
sie packt tatkräftig mit an
[Musik]
für diese schüler ist die schule bald zu
ende
umso mehr genießen sie noch einmal das
gruppengefühl als amstutz die klasse vor
drei jahren übernahm war das noch ganz
anders tätig da können sie noch in
verschiedene vor dem krankenhaus
schuljahr ist schlimm eigentlich also ja
ich will schauen wir sind jetzt deine
ganze familie zurück wachse auch für den
lehrer geht im sommer eine ära zu ende
ich glaube sie www ford aus borken
da werde ich mir gedanken gemacht dass
man vordergründige main
ich habe mich ist klar das riesenloch
will dann punkten wenn auch das wäre
toll wieder eröffnet
ja glaubt hier ist oft nervig sind aber
dabei hat sich mehr gedanken gemacht
dass man meint drüber lehrern hat das
projekt einen schlussstrich ziehen und
mal gar nicht machen dann doch manchmal
denke ich ich es normale pc schul und
vieles ganz angst bald wird hanspeter
amstutz sein schulzimmer rom
das fällt ihm nicht leicht denn lehrer
sein war für ihn nie ein job sondern
berufung zeitlebens wollte er nie etwas
anderes machen
sein inneres feuer lodert bis heute wenn
nur noch wenige wochen
das zu gehen im moment nichts geschieht
müssen so viele abschlüsse dass sie gar
nicht irgendwie starke kühltruhe oder
abschied aber sicher war die dann
möglichen mit dem velo nach den
sommerferien da aber es fehlt der biss
sich auf typische bis losziehung die
förderung damals fiel deshalb beides
gehe oder ob veraltet oder nicht
hans-peter amstutz war mit begeisterung
lehrer und vielleicht ist es das was am
ende zählt dass er alles worden die
regierung
[Applaus]